[Music]
in Illuminati confirmed news I basically
confirm everything as Lewin are
submitted by magical unicorn that's
Illuminati bus C Beyonce's former
drummer claims beyonce is a witch who
cast a spell on her it's confirmed
recurring Wow okay
I don't know Illuminati does witchcraft
well did you know about Illuminati being
like it's Satanism panic but not which
is that's not which is not which is
that's not Wicca witches are good
actually
remember what everyone's doing with you
like 13 it's like super sexy the crap
like 10 unlimited weather did it work
for you a little bit I didn't know it
would work yeah I was pretty crazy
actually we left up my little cousin
like into a ceiling panel I'm not
kidding you're lying I'm not kidding I
swear on my life I swear it works for us
too but there were 14 of us Oh what
makes it kind of easier I guess 14
year-olds fight as a feather 17 of you
picking him up at all 14 14 year olds
yeah exactly
if I coming out there was only five
girls of us like and the one girl was
laying and so there's only four of us
and we like only used fingers and it
actually worked
yeah I don't know how is your friend
weigh 90 pounds fire like 70 pounds like
this high from here to here floor no no
it's a here oh yeah yeah no it was
crates like to the point where like I
was like freaked out like did you let go
and then she fell no put her back down
but I was like I will never do that
again
you probably had one friend that was
like this with her entire
and you guys like wow this is so easy
it's the buff one know whenever we did
it never wind up that I really like this
but that's why I didn't believe it so
I'm like well you could just like I
don't know you're pushing yourself with
your butt or something I don't get I
don't understand it well anyway so this
rubber knife
Beyonce's former drummer her name is
Kimberly didn't even know she had a
drummer oh yeah man or like people
that's a very good Beyonce the band's I
didn't know she has a live band that was
just a drum kit I didn't like the image
it like pop and R&B lay maybe for her
life
it sounds like a made-up job like I'm at
a Hollywood party and it's like oh hi
I'm Bollywood I'm Beyonce's drummer yeah
you're not Beyonce's drummer and usually
like they have people that rotate around
and whoever's available and like the
venue's band yeah but this girl she is
now claiming that beyonce has used
witchcraft against her
let me guess she's witchcraft could make
her lose her job extreme witchcraft
something a sport you shouldn't call it
that if she wants people to take her
seriously
yeah just sounds like something they
offered the X Games pretty good extreme
witchcraft it's like a dirt biking white
guy from the desert obviously like they
just had a bunch of college ins like
lined up and then you had a bunch of
people like helmets off oh yeah she also
wrote it so she is because she was
filing for a civil harassment
restraining order against Beyonce and
that's how we have these terms she put
that in court she put that in the
patient's oh my god witchcraft and magic
spells of sexual molestation interesting
white magic spells yes she also was
molestation spells do you how do you do
that what does that mean well if you
just get molested by a
I don't know kind of like that magic
that's kind of sexy Oh crashing I don't
want to get molested if that's not
getting [ __ ] by a ghost yeah yeah Oh
that'd be tight
what if it's a ugly ghost I wouldn't
know it's like invisible oh yeah what if
it's like an old Civil War ghosts fine
thanks oh look some people can't even
get it up in real life
I mean not you baby that was delivered
with the most conviction I've ever I
mean when there's Mexican food involved
oh that for sure I fully acknowledge and
accept that that is a hundred percent of
fact for dinner Mexican food yeah I'm
like okay pretty much yeah what is it
this spice sometimes if I know we're
going well we'll just have sex before
hand oh my face is covered yeah you go
nuts
pretty youtuber friend of mine used to
do that as a defensive mechanism to make
sure he didn't have sex with his
girlfriend and then he later came out as
gay I don't have to give so many clues
in that there's so many games dude
that's like picking up a booking on
girlfriend who you're friends with my
friends with so many youtubers he's out
of your mind new information all right
so back to this drummer here who is
accusing Chianti what traffic yes sorry
serious case yes is a very serious so
she's saying that she finally discovered
so by the way she she was Beyonce's
drummer on her all-girl band for about
seven years and she said that throughout
all these years she always put up
Beyonce open up head of soul like she
you know admired her a lot she loved her
a lot but then I'm told that [ __ ] put
witch crap on me a motivation witchcraft
yeah well she said that she would cast
spells on her kitten oh no not the
kitten
we don't Beyonce's getting her her own
no no uh-uh Kimberly's kitten not the
molestation spells I hope she's saying
that she cast a spell
her cat and I her cat would attack her
all the time and she's also claiming
that Beyonce murdered her cat
what is kitten dance she's crazy she's
got a lot of to have any proof I mean
what if Beyonce did come over and she's
like what are you doing Beyonce nothing
[ __ ] abracadabra exploded and she's
like and she's like no one will ever be
what if that should happen though
and she just proves away if anyone on
earth could do that I wouldn't think it
would be on say I think it would be
Oprah no but I think that she has the
power never put a molestation spell on
you that's right beyond I feel like the
better the person the more likely they
are a witch yeah exactly
her phone is so good here that like
behind the scenes that's true cuz
youtuber friends that we have like
they're so like online and they're like
super smiley and positive and then
there's like the meanest people a pretty
specific their name tell us more
just give it the [ __ ] away yeah yeah
that's true cuz we'll be like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you but
in a real life oh really nice no we're
beefy we're all beefy yeah we all be
y'all hate each other already the office
jokey we're all beefy I had VP with Ryan
Kazama totally yeah they're totally
gonna believe that anyway so yeah back
to this woman she's saying that this was
all not part of a publicity stunt
because a lot of people are claiming
that she's doing this just to get
publicity out of it by the way I want
you to listen to my one drum single drum
drum I got [ __ ] cursed just so angry
drunk
and by the way I just want to say this
into all ten of these microphones this
is not a publicity stunt she was saying
that she was just trying to cut the cord
because she finally all of them by the
way the sexually molesting spells
whatever Beyonce did that by jumping
from her intimate partners bodies and
different bodies and then that's how she
would molest her you mean well from
jay-z to her nothing like whoever the
girl was hooking up with Beyonce yonk
over their body and molester she's
saying that she touched herself
basically is what she's saying it is
that true no she's saying she was with
the foot like she let's say I'm on a
date with you Beyonce took over your
body and molested me with your body yeah
that's what she's playing me that's what
she that's the hottest [ __ ] I've ever
heard
that's an awesome poverty not really
great yeah and then like she was really
be very important but how would she know
what the beyonce molesting her she is it
like yo it's me Beyonce jump in your
body I was like I'm Beyonce she found
out when she went to Greece who psychic
documents it I don't have just one
psychic I have two seconds but the two
psychics going to testify but she's
spent money on two psychics and no
lawyers cuz a lawyer would have been
like let's changes a little bit what if
one of the psychics is the lawyer took
over a psychics body and they were
telling her the [ __ ] to make her
sound crazy yeah yeah believes her
because true this is the type of person
who sees one of those stickers with a
hologram on it and things like all this
means is what I'm holding is legitimate
because it has this hologram stick hey I
bought one of the seven hundred bricks
from Marshall Mathers you're told no
time childhood home it has
holographic stamp and a signature and
what does that mean by the way what is
the holographic spillage it 100% okay
what is that I understand thank you so
Holograms is like it's like the
authenticity sticker when you hold it
like that cool it kind of moves a little
bit yeah I mean something's legit if it
if there's a sticker on it but wait wait
is it signed yeah I love the brick the
card that comes with the bridge have you
looked I'll guess who signed it a
[ __ ] machine no never never touch
that [ __ ] piece of paper yes no it
didn't bring it in here and you're
Peyton Manning [ __ ] autograph thing
is not legit either no a lot of money is
legit because that's an actual pen and
that's his actual signature your brain
not gone and exploded out your mouths
but also useful in Brandon what does
that mean it's addicting with my lip you
Civil War knows if you're out there play
just save me
[Music]
[Music]